I'd like to thank the organizers very
much for inviting me this is joint work
with just me and chief just bein stand
up Joslyn will answer already difficult
questions we are concerned about these
squares regression and we are using the
statistics notation so petros already
did a little intro but we're starting
here from the Gaussian linear model
where we have a design matrix X that is
a tall and skinny matrix with linearly
independent columns
it has photon Imran and then we want the
parameter beta 0 which is in general
unknown but what we do have our
observations Y which are corrupted by
error so the observation
is the observation error is white and
the arrow is Epsilon and it's a it's
normally distributed with variance Sigma
square so what one does computationally
one sorts of the squares problems one
pixel by one so it's that least squares
form it's the matrix excess full column
rank then one can get a unique maximum
likelihood estimate a better hat which
can be expressed in terms of the matrix
like so we have an inverse here that's
possible because an excess full column
rank so the thing is now inspectors
already mentioned these matrices are
huge they can have many rows so what one
can do is one can do a row compression
so it's the same matrix I guess that
petros use and use only a few of the
rows so one one reduces the role and
reduces the observation and then one
tries to get a minimum known solution
beta Turner so our objective here is to
determine the combined mean and variance
of the two types of uncertainties we
have uncertainty is due to the linear
model and uncertainties due to the
randomization so our inspiration was the
growth breaking work by Mahoney and you
on a statistical perspective and
algorithmic leveraging so what I'd like
to do is a very briefly summarize
existing work and because it's Monday
morning I will do a lot of examples and
then give some structure perturbation
about meaning deterministic ones then we
condition on the model in Houston we
review the world induced uncertainty and
then everything together and then a
summary
okay so there's a lot of existing work
I'm just looking here at role
compression algorithms there's also a
way to work on the columns for example
planes picked by haim and and Sivan and
I'm not going to include it here is not
any of the work on on regularization
that say Alex and and Michael did so
there is a ton of work here on the
random on the randomized algorithms as
well as the statistical properties so
let's just start with some examples some
very simple examples here we have a
design matrix it has two columns they're
linearly independent columns you can see
because here the ones correspond to
zeros here it has a left inverse the
left inverse has one half one half fear
because in that first column we have two
one so this is a left inverse that means
if I multiply X from the left with this
pseudo with that loop n-words inverse I
get the identity so I'm not giving here
on observation wide but the maximum
likelihood estimator then uses this
pseudo inverse and then we can look at
we we attribute the uncertainty now in
the model we attributed to Y so then the
expected value of the solution from the
point of view of Y because Y Y is X beta
zero we take the expected value and
epsilon is expected value zero and this
here is the identity so it's a very
short review for the fact that the
solution from the least squares form is
an unbiased estimator we can also get
the variance because we have zero mean
so the variance is sort of quadratic and
we get this okay we have that okay now
you do sketching let's fix the sketching
matrix s to start but let's just look at
it as a multiplicative perturbation
here's a sketching matrix that has full
rank
it has rank two it has a one year
meaning example it's the first column
and it has a first row any other one
here meaning it samples the second row
so a sketched matrix is the identity
which is great because that means it's
its own inverse so when we put it into
we condition then on the matrix as it's
fixed and then we determine the
expectation with respect to the to the
linear model so we get this Y both of
these guys their identities all over the
place
so because the sketching matrix has full
column rank we get an unbiased estimator
and we can also figure out the variance
again this is the formula for the
variance everybody inside is the
identity so that's what we get so if you
now look at the variance of the of this
solution from the Patel problem you see
it has increased with regard to the
lunar partial order so in this case the
variance has increased now if we take
another sketching matrix again the
sketching matrix s has full roll rank
the two rows are linearly independent
but the rows it samples from X are this
one and this one so now the sketched
matrix is rank deficient there is no
inverse anymore so we have to take the
pseudo inverse to get a minimum known
solution
so now this times this is not the
identity anymore
it's just this so in general for general
p0 this is not equal to be 0 anymore
better 0 so we have a biased estimator
and also if you put this matrix into the
formula for the variance you'll see that
the variance is singular so to sum up
what we see from our little example is
that if the SCAF you fix the sketching
matrix and if it preserves rank then you
have a nice left inverse so you're
allowed to take this inverse and then
the conditional estimator is an unbiased
estimator it has the same it's equal to
the same value that you would get from
the Gaussian linear model so you haven't
messed anything up with the sketching in
terms of bias if the sketching matrix
loses right you cannot take that inverse
anymore then you get a biased estimator
and the variance is singular
okay so in general what the hell doesn't
have a fixed sampling matrix so here we
are doing uniform sampling with
replacement we are sampling two rows out
of four so si J denotes the various
instances of the sampling matrix we can
get so the first row of s can
sample any of the four rows of X the
second row of s can sample any of the
four rows of X so we have four times
four sixteen probability so it's one one
says that oh it's because it's would
replace two examples the first row of X
twice as for two summits the fourth row
of X and then the second row of X so you
get these so if we want to get the the
if we take the expectation over s we see
it's an unbiased estimator we have a
1/16 here because we have 16 different
instances of s of them can occur with
the same probability so in terms of you
know this is the the deviation of this
of the columns of s from orthonormality
in expectation they are orthonormal and
they're equal to the identity okay so if
we now use what we had from before to
get the total mean we conditioned
sequentially so we conditioned with
regard to the linear model after that we
conditioned with regard to the sampling
matrix so we get this here
and now we just have to sit down and
work it all out you know the expected
value goes over all possible values of s
which in this case we can figure out you
sit down with paper and pencil you have
a lot of patience and you get that well
that thing is not the identity and that
thing multiplies beta0 so that means in
expectation you don't have an unbiased
estimator and in particular try out of
the 16 sketched matrices are ranked
efficient okay so that's a little
example
so as Petra said the first thing in
analyzing randomized algorithms often
could have structural deterministic
perturbation bounds so here we have our
exact problem we have to go with that a
hat matrix and also a projector on to
the column space of X and because X in
our case is the full rank matrix the
pseudo inverse can be can be just
expressed in terms of X so the range of
the projector is exactly the range of
the of the design matrix and our
solution well we have an inverse here
pseudo inverse and you can also I'm
doing the
because we need this it can be
represented as the pseudo-inverse
applied to the projection of the
observation onto the column space away
okay now there's the perturbed problem
why for the perturb from the matrix is
SX but we can't take an inverse we can't
construct the pseudo inverse from that
inverse because in general that matrix
is rank deficient plus s X has many
fewer rows than X so we have two types
of these gray spots to deal with one
with many rows one with a few rows we
somehow have to compare them so for that
purpose we construct the comparison hat
matrix which is with regard to the
original matrix X so this project o here
has the same number of rows as the fat
matrix and it's range is contained
within the range of X and it's exactly
equal to the range of the original
matrix X if that projector has full
column rank meaning our sketch matrix
has full column rank and then we can
represent our solution and again this
inverse and then we have the comparison
hat matrix here instead of the original
matrix so this projector is a little bit
more general than what Michael and
Darvish was Kuti had our project was
equal to this when the matrix a
successful column rank but for for rank
the fresh matrices they're sort of
doesn't work so here we are here we have
to design matrix so you see you have two
columns and you have nonzero elements
and three rows you can see that in the
projector here - this is the first
column this is the second column this is
the first column again so if we take a
sketching matrix that preserves rank
like this one here that picks the first
two rows of X the projector P the
comparison hat matrix rapid uses the
first two columns of X because it starts
out with X here and then this stuff here
is full rank however if you have a
sketching matrix that lose its rank and
that picks rows 1 and 4 of X where we
have 0 here you can see that only the
first column of X is preserved and
because this thing is ranked efficient
the other stuff is lost so you can see
that this projector gets only part of
the range of the
the design matrix it misses out on this
column so so here we are again so we can
this is our original solution this is
the solution from the sketch prom and
you can see we can write the sketched
solution as the original solution plus
the difference between the two and the
difference between the two is a
difference between an oblique projector
and an orthogonal projector so the
difference between the two solution is
proportional to the difference between
the hat and the comparison hat matrix so
it's a very nice geometric way of
looking at things so from that we can
get my duplicative perturbation board
which may only be of interest to the
numerical people in here but this is
only one slide and then we go back to
other things so here we have the
condition um of the design matrix in the
two non that is the ratio of the largest
over the smallest singular value it
tells you something about how the matrix
this deforms a unit sphere if that
condition number is large then when the
matrix acts on the unit sphere through
it for users an ellipse that is that has
a very huge aspect ratio and then we
also interested in the angle between the
range of the design matrix and the
observation vector Y to see how much can
the matrix capture the observations and
from from the previous expression we can
get a bound for the error in the in the
sketched solution it we can view this
the difference between the two
projectors as the perturbation that is
amplified by the condition number of X
the aspect ratio over the cosine of the
angle so that means there's a lot of
amplification if the condition um of the
matrix X si and if Y is very far away
the observation is very far away from
the from the design matrix or the design
matrix has a really hard time capturing
the observations and that's also been a
least-squares proposal condition and in
the deterministic setting okay so these
bounds are tighter than what what has
happened before okay so now let's look
at the model induced uncertainty let's
assume s is fixed we fix it as sketching
matrix or sampling matrix so here we
have the solution we can
the solution can see that we can get the
conditional mean as is fixed so the only
thing we are that has a nonzero expected
value as Y and expected value is X beta
zero so if the sketched matrix preserves
rank then the pseudo inverse is left
inverse we have the identity here and
the solution is an unbiased estimator
however if the sketched matrix loses
rank then you can see by adding and
subtracting beta 0 here that we have a
rank deficiency a deviation from from
unbiasness so if we can see that this is
this is what we want it but this is what
we get so that means our deviation or
our bias increases with the right
efficiency of this thing of the sketched
matrix ok so for the variance we can or
the variance the marriages are always
more unpleasant because they are
quadratic right so we have our hat
matrix for the original from the
projector on to the on to the range of x
then we have the comparison hat matrix
this is the original variance which we
can also write like this for comparison
so that we can express the variance of
the sketched solution as the variance of
the original solution plus a mess but if
you look inside this mess what you have
here is PP transpose minus P sub X so
this is the hat matrix your sublet
projector onto the range of X that
matrix is nice it's symmetric and it's
idempotent it's being compared to PP
transpose
well if P was also symmetric and I'd
imported this would be solved so this
thing here is the deviation of the
comparison matrix from being an
orthogonal projector from doing the
right thing from capturing the column
space of X ok so here's the summary now
so we fixed the sketching matrix and we
want you to see what does that do to the
biasness of the solution is it still an
unbiased estimate or is it not so we saw
that if the sketch matrix still has full
column right the sketch solution is
unbiased if it doesn't then the bias
increases with the amount of rank
lost by the sketched matrix the
conditional barrier is close to the to
the model variance if that comparison
hat matrix is close to doing its job and
ruffled using the column space of X and
if X is also where condition with
respect to left inversions and if the
sketch matrix loses rain you have a
singular variance okay so now if we put
everything together that's great I
finish I finished early maybe okay so
here we are now we put everything
together so what we can show is that the
total mean if we look at the uncertainty
from the randomization and the
uncertainty from the linear problem so
this is our what we would like and here
is what we have so it's the expected
value of all instances of s and then we
look at how that whether how close that
is to being the identity matrix and we
are doing that over all instances of s
so we can see that the X that's the
expected deviation of the sketch matrix
from the identity so you have a job an
oil sketching matrices s try out how
close this thing is to being a left
inverse you can do that by subtracting
the identity so that means the total
bias is proportional to the expected
deviation of the sketching matrix from
identity and the variance is a mess
again but you can see here we have two
terms so the variance of the sketched
solution is is equal to the original
variance and then there are two other
terms this is the expected value of the
comparison hat matrix from being an
orthogonal project onto the column space
of X before we are just this expression
now we as we're averaging over all
sketching matrices and then here in the
variance we have the deviation of the
sketched matrix from full column rank so
these are the two things so these are
these are these are qualities right so
this is what the variance is like it's
not pretty
but that's what it is and we can get the
geometric picture out of it okay so now
I wanted to look at two cases again two
tools so we were going to look at a best
the worst case so if we look at a design
matrix X what's the best design matrix
we can sample from well as Petrus
already mentioned they are leveraged
scores so it would be a matrix whose
columns or columns of a harem our matrix
because you see X it's an orthogonal
matrix don't know I mean it has a
thermal columns not orthonormal calls
but the mass is very distributed there's
no zero
everybody has magnitude 1 and the two
columns are linearly independent so the
mass is as uniform as it gets this is
the orthogonal project or on on to the
range and so now if we sample two rows
uniformly and with replacement then the
expected value if we look at the
deviation of the sample matrices from
ranked efficiency you know there are 16
instances of the of the sample of the
sampling made to expect I showed at the
beginning we see that this is the
identity it's sort of one-fourth of the
identity and if we look at the expected
deviation of this matrix of the P from
being an orthogonal projector we get
this okay so you can also do that with
the worst case the matrix that has
highly concentrated mass and has has bad
coherence so this is as bad as it gets
for matrix with two columns right the
masses so it's a matrix that has two
linearly independent columns and the
mass is concentrated upstairs so this is
the orthogonal projector that goes with
it and now if we look at the if we see
if we averaged over all its sampling
matrices and and look at the expected
deviation of the sample matrix from full
column rank is we see it's minus 9/16 so
it's more than twice as much as in the
best case and similarly for the for the
orthogonal projector so what can one can
compute these things the question is now
how does one make sense of those but
these are not bounds those eye quality
so the the problem here is now how does
one interpret these things
so to summarize I have looked at
randomized row sketching for full column
rank regression and we did not look
inside the sampling matrices except for
the examples so you can take you can
take any sampling matrix and apply that
framework so we got exact expressions
for the uncertainties combined
uncertainty
due to model and randomization and we
introduced the comparison hack matrix to
allow comparisons between the sketch
perm which has many fewer columns and
the original problem we got
deterministic bounds which are tighter
than existing ones and we saw that the
total mean and variance likes are
governed by the expected deviation of
the sketched matrices from full column
rank and the comparison hat matrix from
doing the job of the of the hat matrix
being an orthogonal projector and we we
gave examples to illustrate the
applicability and then there is a paper
on archive and before I finish I'd like
to make a plot for two things for one
thing we have a postdoc position and
data science at NC State so he is
applying it so it starts next academic
year and then we also have a book series
on data science and we have three
associate editors here Michael and David
Woodruff so anything that is too long to
be a journal paper qualifies to be a
candidate for the book series so we are
awaiting your requests and interest in
the book series thank you very much
Thank You scenario as well we actually
have time for questions and I'm happy to
take questions for my talk as well I
didn't want to do it before it's just
not to run longer one of these citizen
busy with high probability that the so
that would be the next step we haven't
looked inside the sampling matrices so
we were you know we were inspired by it
by the work that my continue and and
Kingma have done so we first sort of
revisited their work which was in a very
global context and so we have committed
to particular sampling matrices that
would be the next step to do do the
issues with like is is then the variance
case kind of simple or is it still like
you can tune stuff to kind of optimize
it so I talked to him did I talk gave it
would know somebody you could of course
take the sketched matrix if it's ranked
the efficient you could regular Isaac
and then you know but then I it's it's
not clear at all we know miles might
West Wales
well then miles has looked at those
things what it's it's it's harder to
analyze regularizing the sketched matrix
right isn't that what you said you're
the statistician right
it's not a talker so it's this is our
value-free we are not advocating
anything we're just giving you that that
framework and take it or leave it
so looking inside the sampling rate is
committing to particular types of
sampling matrices that's the next step
so yes other words like you were always
able to just condition fix the sketch
matrix so you fixed that then you
analyze the randomness from the input
but I imagine often you also have
randomness on the actual input matrix so
you know for me as a numerical analysts
that the round of errors and we have
here there's a whole other kind of work
so we this is all in exact arithmetic so
for me the next thing would be to look
at one what if the design matrix is
afflicted with round of errors what do
they do to everything yeah so that's
another thing to look at
so what auslan has plenty of work to do
any other questions okay
[Applause]